Çeviri: Gözde Caymazer
Gözden geçirme: Yunus ASIK
Ece Temelkuran
Yazar
Amerikan üssü olan bir şehirde
büyümüş bir arkadaşım,
kardeşiyle şöyle bir oyun oynuyormuş:
Amerikacılık oyunu.
Oyun şöyle.
Günün herhangi bir anında
birbirlerine diyorlar ki,
hadi Amerikalılar gibi olalım.
Ondan sonra da böyle yapıyorlar,
filan, böyle davranmaya başlıyorlar.
Şimdi buralar bu tür sahneler,
bizden biraz Amerikacılık oyunu
oynamamızı bekleyen sahneler.
Bu sahne benden size Anglo-Amerikan
tarzında bir hikâye anlatmamı bekliyor.
İşte bu hikâye kişisel olacak,
muhakkak komik olacak
ve size dokunmam gerekiyor,
dokunaklı olması gerekiyor
ve elbette hiç notlarıma
bakmamam lazım.
Ama her ne kadar hani dünyanın ikisi hariç
bütün kıtalarında hikâye anlatmış,
hikâye yazmış bir insan olarak
bir cephanem olsa da bu konuda,
benim bugün böyle bir şey
yapmak içimden gelmiyor.
Bu sahneler çünkü insandan çoğu
zaman şöyle bir şey bekliyor.
Siz buraya geleceksiniz,
motive olacaksınız,
ilham alacaksınız
ve tazelenerek zaten var olan hayatınızı
devam ettirmek üzere
dışarı çıkacaksınız.
Ben, bugün burada niye varız?
Ben de sizle.
İşte noktaları birleştireceğiz.
Nereden çıktı bu?
Steve Jobs’tan.
Steve Jobs kim?
Son kırk yıldır falan herhâlde
iletişim kültürümüzü
ve sonrada bizi biçimlendiren bir adam.
Steve Jobs sayesindedir ki biz bugün
sadakat ve heyecanın mükemmel
birleşimi olan tek aşk ilişkimizi
telefonlarımızla yaşıyoruz.
Ve Steve Jobs’un söylediği şey şu:
"Eğer geçmişe bakarak
noktaları birleştirebilirsek,
ortaya bir resim çıkar
ve hayatı anlayabiliriz."
Ben size bugün büyük resim
veremeyeceğim.
Onun yerine bir X çizeceğim.
Buna şimdilik
''İnsanlığın Büyük X’i'' diyelim.
TEDx'in küçük x'i gibi değil,
daha büyük bir X.
Çünkü bence önümüzdeki yüzyılın meselesi,
İnsanlığın Büyük X'i olacak.
Neden?
Çünkü kendimize bakıyoruz.
Lüzumundan fazla kendimizle ilgiliyiz.
Dünyanın geri kalanı
sanki çektiğimiz selfilerde,
sığdığı kadarıyla küçük bir
manzara parçası.
Ve bu büyük ahlaki yanılgımız
o kadar meşru ki,
böyle yerlere gelip,
bu kadar büyük toplantılar yapıp
--bugün böyle değil
ama genelde böyle oluyor--
böyle büyük toplantılar yapıp
dünyanın ciddi meselelerinden
hiçbirini konuşmadan ayrılabiliyoruz.
Oysa bugün dünyada ne oluyor?
Batı medeniyetinin bildiğimiz
anlamda sınırları daralıyor.
Batı medeniyetinin doğduğu yer olan
Ege denizi sahillerine çocuk
cesetleri vuruyor.
İnsan hakları beyannamesinin
imzalandığı şehirde
insanoğlu kendini bombalarla patlatıyor.
Eşitsizliği, adaletsizliği gezegenin
güneyine depolamış,
outsource etmiş dünya,
artık orada biriken öfkeyi
durdurabilecek kadar yüksek,
o kadar kalın duvarlar öremeyeceğinin
farkına varıyor bir gün.
Keşke sadece bu kadar olsa.
Bir de şöyle bir şey oluyor.
Gezegen kuruyor.
Artık insanlar topraksız tarım
yapmayı düşünüyorlar.
Bence önümüzdeki yüzyılın
en büyük ahlaki sorunsalı,
insanoğlu için en büyük soru şu olacak:
Bu gezegendeki beceriksizliğimizi kabul
edip buradan gidelim mi?
Yoksa bir kere daha deneyelim mi?
Çözüm ne?
Da dad dad da daaa.
Şimdi...
Vatikan'da Papa,
ondan sonra Amerika'da Demokrat Parti
aday adayı Bernie Sanders,
arkasından dünyanın en
zenginlerinden Bill Gates
ve hatta Hollywood'da Brad Pitt
ve en son Türkiye'deki iş dünyasının
devlerinden Ali Koç,
sosyalizmden adlı adınca bahsettiğine göre
artık benim de böyle bir sahnede
sosyalizm demem garip kaçmayacaktır.
(Alkışlar)
Geçtiğimiz yüzyıl boyunca bu sözcükten
hepimizi korkuttular.
Kötülüğün efendisi, şeytanların en başı.
Sosyalizm hep böyle oldu.
Oysa, sosyalizm çok basit bir şey.
Söylüyorum.
Rekabet yerine dayanışma.
Hırs yerine yaşam coşkusu.
Sahip olmak yerine olmak.
Korku değil sevgi.
Ama tabii en önemlisi,
tek başına değil hep beraber.
Sadece bunu söyledikleri için
7 kıtada geçtiğimiz yüzyıl boyunca
katledilmiş milyonlarca insanın önünde
saygıyla eğilerek söylüyorum ki,
X'imizin insanlık,
insanlığın büyük X'inin ilk çizgisi,
kapitalizmle sosyalizm arasında çizilecek.
Önümüzdeki yüzyılın meselesi bu olacak.
Çünkü biraz önce zikrettiğim
isimlerin aracılığıyla
kapitalist utangaç da olsa kapitalistler,
sosyalizmi pazarlık masasına çağırdılar.
Kapitalistler çok akıllı adamlardır,
öyle durup dururken bir şey yapmazlar.
Muhtemelen kapitalizmin büyük
krizini engellemek için,
bir yumuşak iniş yapmak için,
kendilerini kurtarmak için
yapmış olabilirler.
Ama bir kez pazarlık masasına
oturulduğunda,
ne olacağını kimse bilemez.
Peki bunu kim yapacak?
Bu büyük çizgiyi kim çekecek?
Bu da bizi X'in ikinci büyük
çizgisine götürüyor.
Bu çizgiye --İngilizce ismi daha havalı
olduğu için öyle söyleyeceğim--
Andalusia Reloaded diyelim.
Endülüs Yeniden.
Yıllar yıllar yıllar önce, insanlığın
doğusu ile batısı birbirine değdi
ve oradan insanlığın en güzel fikirleri,
en güzel şarkıları,
en güzel şiirleri
ve en güzel şarapları çıktı.
Endülüs.
Bunun yeniden gündeme
geleceği kanaatindeyim.
Çünkü bu bir kere oldu.
Bir kere bunun küçük bir girişimi oldu.
Tahrir’deki insanlar,
İspanya meydanlarındaki insanlar,
Atina'daki insanlar,
İstanbul'daki, Gezi'deki,
Türkiye'deki insanlar,
birbirleri ile konuşmaya başladılar,
ayaklanırken.
Ve tam o ayaklanma anında,
güven satın almak için milyonlarca
dolar yatırılmış olan,
o büyük logolu haber ağlarını
bir kenara ittiler.
Hiç tanımadıkları, üstelik gerçek
isimlerini bile bilmedikleri
takma isimli insanlara güvendiler.
Onlardan bilgi almak istediler,
onlardan haber almak istediler.
Bu çok önemlidir.
İnsan insanı seçmiştir.
Bu Endülüs Yeniden'in
bir başlangıcı bence
ve devamı gelecek diye düşünüyorum.
X'imiz dünyanın birbirine,
gezegenin, insanlığın birbirine en uzak
iki noktası, dört noktası
arasında kurulacak.
Kapitalizm'le Sosyalizm.
Doğu'yla Batı arasında.
Bunun, bu X'in tam ortasında
insanlık cennetinin,
yeryüzündeki cennetin
durduğunu düşünüyorum
ve oraya odaklanmamız
gerektiği kanaatindeyim.
Şu anda dağınık ve bulanık hâlde
yaşadığımız 3. Dünya Savaşı'nın
sonunun gelmesinin tek imkânının da
bu olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Yıllar önce Arjantin'de kriz yaşanırken,
barikat eylemcileri vardı,
2001'di galiba.
Ben de oradaydım, barikat
eylemcileriyle birlikteydim,
gazeteciydim o zaman.
Ve gündüzleri sırtına bebeğini
bağlayıp, yollara çıkıp
elinde metal bir çubukla
polislerle kavga eden
ve Buenos Aires'e giren
dört ana arterden birini
kesenlerin lideri olan bir kızla tanıştım.
Gencecik ufak tefek bir kız.
Bebeği de var.
Böyle sarmış bebeğini sırtına.
Maria.
Onun kulübesine gittik,
bir yataktan başka hiçbir şeyi yok.
Ve çok uzun konuştuk konuştuk.
Sosyalizm o bu falan filan.
Ondan sonra dedim ki "Maria neden?
Yani sonuç olarak neden?
Neden yapıyorsun bunu?"
O da şöyle dedi:
"Hafta içi çalışmak istiyorum, hafta sonu
da tangoya gitmek istiyorum."
(Gülüşmeler)
İnsan devasa ve minnacık bir şey.
Korkunç ve hayranlık verici.
Gezegen de öyle.
Bir rezalet, büyük bir becerisizlik
ve hâlâ her nasılsa bizi
kendine hayran bırakıyor.
Ben burada ikinci bir şansı
hak ettiğimizi düşünüyorum.
Bu yüzden de diyorum ki,
bu yaz sahillerde self-help kitapları
yerine sosyalizm okuyun.
Çünkü önümüzdeki on yılın trendy topic'i
bu olacak arkadaşlar. (Gülüşmeler)
Teşekkürler.
(Alkışlar)